la unión europea y eeuu han cerrado un
acuerdo para aumentar la exportación de
gas natural licuado proveniente desde
eeuu un importante pacto que implica que
alrededor de 15 mil millones de metros
cúbicos se puedan exportar hacia la
unión europea proveniente desde estados
unidos y sus aliados esto es un aumento
del 66 por ciento respecto a lo que se
hace ahora la unión europea insiste en
que hay que reducir la dependencia del
gas ruso y que hay que confiar en socios
como eeuu en qatar pero también aumentar
la presencia de las energías renovables
pero esta factura no va a salir gratis
el gas natural liquado es mucho más caro
que transportarlo desde rusia hay que
convertirlo transportarlo y también
distribuirlo entre todos los países y no
todos tienen un almacenaje adecuada aún
así la comisión europea insiste en que
hay que mantener los precios de la
electricidad y del gas a rajatabla de
hecho insiste en que este mismo año ya
haya un almacenaje de alrededor del 80
por ciento de gas para evitar que los
precios se disparen
en cualquier caso esto va a ser una de
las grandes discusiones de la reunión de
aquí de líderes europeos cómo hacer que
los precios del gas y de la electricidad
no estén tan volátiles como actualmente
países como españa y bélgica van a
insistir hoy que se limite el precio del
gas para que así esto no afecte a los
precios de la electricidad aunque países
como alemania no lo ven nada claro
porque insiste en que el sistema
energético de cada país es muy distinto
así que se espera una reunión muy larga
aquí en bruselas